let's do this holy geez
it's bad
the nine ring broadsword
the nine ring broadsword is a variant on
the Chinese Dao from the King Dynasty
that was used through the 1930s
featuring a blade wider than a
traditional down and a curve towards the
tip the weapon was ideal for chopping
and could sever ahead with a single
swing
the rings on the back of the blade serve
dual purposes for ornamentation used
during ceremonies or martial arts
displays and for superstitious reasons
as it was believed the jingling sound
would ward off evil spirits this deadly
and sacred sword can be seen on the
television show into the Badlands
Smiths
you have all gratitude
[Music]
gentlemen your swords look magnificent
but are they deadly
to find that out we will take your
swords and deliver some clean blows on
this big carcass
it's all about the kill in this
particular test Britain you are first
are you ready sir yes sir let's do this
damn
two
three
oh
well there one
man
[Music]
oh my goodness look at that
all right Burton first stop what I love
about this blade was the balance the way
I was able to move with the blade
everywhere
now let's talk about the breakage okay
so the break happened right there where
the ring was attached you can see it's
really not a bad poor structure you have
there it could be finer but rings when
you're digging into that could cause
stress risers and it broke right there
where the ring was
well gentlemen the fight's not over
because Mike your blade still has to
survive nine strikes on its kill test
Target good luck gentlemen Doug
if I make it through nine strikes on
this pig I'm forged and fire Champion my
Palms are sweating I'm so scared that
this thing's gonna break on the first
swing
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Burton unfortunately your blade broke it
can no longer continue with testing and
for that reason I have to dismiss you
from the forge
it's a good job brother I appreciate it
mine sucks
seeing my blade break uh it's a
disappointment you know when you make it
to round three you want to win
you know the nine holes burnt through
four drill bits doing them so somewhere
through there I probably was given a
little too much pressure and caused the
stress riser to run down that blade that
was enough to cause a critical failure
in that blade I'm still proud of myself
with what I've done you know it was way
out of my wheelhouse uh what's next for
me is not swords especially any nine
ring swords that's for damn sure
Mike congratulations the strength and
integrity of your blade has made you a
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother
I have one Fortune fire holy crap man
come on forward and Shake our hands
thank you
good job though thank you so some of the
things that went wrong in my home Forge
I was really sure that that blade was
going to break on me yeah
it was a happy dance
enjoy your day
the toureg takoba
[Music]
the takova is a type of broadsword that
has been used by the nomadicator people
of North Africa since the 14th century
this double-edged lightweight blade was
carried for self-defense on Long
Journeys designed to deliver lethal
slashes and stabs against a rival
Warrior
due to the torg's aversion to iron there
is no exposed steel or iron on the hilt
of the sword so it cannot touch the
user's hand measuring more than a meter
long this deadly weapon was seen as a
symbol of wealth some members of the
Tacoma Clan still carry this weapon
today
Smiths welcome to the Keel test
your turretto kobus look beautiful but
the kind of beauty I'm looking for is
the lethal kind I'm going to take your
weapon delivers some lethal blows in
this ballistic stummy dusting you up
first you ready yes sir let's do this
[Applause]
right Dustin let's talk about your
weapon here first up your handle
Construction
I like the avoid feel of this the flare
you have there in your pommel actually
gives great retention for this your tip
is sharp enough to penetrate your edges
are sharp when you're cutting out and
you can wheel this
to do that kind of damage on this but
it's dummy
overall sir a weapon like this
it will kill awesome
all right Joshua your turn you ready
keep everyone alive all right let's do
this
foreign
all right Joshua let's talk about your
weapon here your pommel right here could
have used some weight to it but because
it's forward weighted and the fact that
you have a very sharp edge every slice
as you can see is very deep into the
ballistic stummy and more importantly
sir your weapon
you will kill
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our desert well chop
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades I will be
chopping into our well house as well as
the well Dustin you're on Deck you ready
I guess so
okay
foreign
[Music]
we were doing so well for a moment there
what actually happened was
with insetting your blade down into this
piece of wood
any of that leverage was just too much
for the wood itself and it popped it
loose
your Tang is a little bit small but what
I do like to see is that your blade
actually held up beautiful
I mean your grain structure looks fine
this is an absolutely brutal test it's
very well done thank you
now Dustin you survived every one of the
strikes except for the last one your
guard gave way and your blade followed
so we consider this a catastrophic
failure cannot continue testing your
blade but you're not out of the fight
yet how you feeling Joshua pressure's on
all right so you need to survive five
strikes in order to be named Forge and
fire Champion you ready yes sir all
right let's do it
foreign
well Joshua your blade is strong it made
it past all the strikes congratulations
now Dustin unfortunately for you that
means your time here in this competition
has ended because you did have a
catastrophic failure it was an honor
watching you in our Forge but
unfortunately man at this time I'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off our
fourth floor
thank you guys thank you so much I'm
definitely crushed I actually thought
that recessing the sword into the Tang a
little bit would make it stronger and
that's kind of what bit me in the end so
definitely definitely won't be doing
that again
I'm definitely proud of this blade I
came here to challenge myself as much as
I could and I definitely achieved that
well Joshua congratulations man that
means you are the newest Fortune fire
Champion you just got yourself a check
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
[Applause]
oh my gosh I made a sword it didn't
break oh my God
it was a hard competition so this is
unreal
the Polish Carabella
one of Europe's most iconic Savers the
Carabella was the sidearm of history's
most fearsome Calvary the winged hussars
these 17th century Warriors famed for
their feathered armor and sophisticated
attack formations brandished the sword
on Horseback when closing in on the
enemy the saber's light curved blades
slashed easily through enemy armor its
Hilt often included fixtures that
improved grip and Recovery like a thumb
ring chain guard or curved eagle head
pommel the Carabella was so effective at
helping the husars defeat enemy armies
much larger in size that it became a
symbol of prestige worn by polish
Lithuanian nobility at formal events its
Legacy lives on in the video game series
Witcher
late Smits this is the kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your weapon
will do I will take your weapon deliver
some slashes and thrust on this big
carcass
Ethan you're first you ready I am so
ready
[Music]
all right how'd it feel
first up there are no issues whatsoever
with your Edge over here it is sharp it
lacerates and cuts cleaning look at that
Razor Cuts right there on the thrust you
have an angle here that allowed for a
deep thrust pulling out and slashing on
the way out overall your weapon will
kill
all right Leon your turn you ready oh
yeah let's do it so many things can go
wrong I don't even know if I was able to
get a good solid temper on this blade
foreign
[Music]
let me say this first up your presses
here is a victory all the things that
you went through and you still turn in a
blade that's beautiful in craftsmanship
that is very sharp but your blade did
break and you can see right here in the
cross section it's just a discoloration
down here so something happened in your
heat treating process it may have Micro
fractures
it is what it is
Liam there is a flaw in your blade that
led to a catastrophic blade failure and
we can no longer continue with testing
for that reason I have to ask you to
please leave the forge
thank you gentlemen
I'm upset Sometimes the best you can do
isn't going to be enough but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't still try
Ethan this is a competition where the
best blade wins and you sir our new
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check ten
thousand dollars good job
I really would have liked to have seen
both of those go all the way through
testing but I'm very proud of the work I
did I'm now a foraging fire champion
Attila the Huns sword of Mars
oh
yes known as The Scourge you got it till
of the Hun was one of the most feared
conquerors in history the leader of the
hunnic Empire his group of nomadic
tribes wreaked havoc across Europe
during the 5th Century though he was
once a great Ally to them he played
Roman territories sacking major cities
like Constantinople Legend states that
Attila was given the sword of Mars by a
herdsman fulfilling a prophecy and a
direct sign from the Roman war god Mars
of his Divine rule the Lethal Weapon
featured a curved handle with a spear
Point tip that gave it exceptional
control allowing for accurate and brutal
thrust after attila's death in the year
453 the Hanukkah Empire quickly
dissolved however the story of attila's
many conquests still live on through the
television miniseries Attila alright
bladesmiths to find out what kind of
lethal damage your weapon will do I will
deliver killing blows on this for the
sixth dummy Randy up first you ready I
am let's do this
nice
all right trying to talk about your
sword of Mars here first up the Damascus
pattern you have here is gorgeous all
right the weapon design is very
aggressive for thrusting and slashing
now your handle construction if you
reverse this it'll be easier to have
something to lock onto the fact that the
flare is right here forcing my hand to
open up if I want to marry into the hilt
this is a very sharp weapon the tip
pierces all the way through cuts on the
way out it's pointy and scary and it
will kill thank you good job all right
Dan it is your turn you ready oh yeah
let's do this I was hoping the kill test
would be a dummy I no heads will roll
all right dance talk about your weapon
here I love the balance of your blade
when I go forward it's not hard to pull
back to go in again for another kill now
you're handled construction it's curved
enough to where it doesn't want to fly
out of my hand it's got a good grip and
control for this your Edge allows for
very deep cuts into the abdomen right
there the only issue we have is that
your tip picked up a Bend when it's
chopped into the spine
but your weapon sir will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now attila's armies were
basically one large Cavalry and through
his military campaigns he revolutionized
the use of horse in military conflicts
so to test the strength and durability
of your blades I'll be chopping into
these horse skulls
Randy you're up first you ready I guess
so
foreign
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
okay so right off the bat the biggest
thing is that this section from right
about here to here
has lost its Edge
there's a couple of small rolls
blades still straight it's all in one
piece still solid nicely done it's a
very strong button all right Dan are you
ready no but let's do it
everybody says that
[Music]
the guard
[Music]
okay so before we get to the obvious I
really like the design of your blade
it's got a great weight to it had a
really good feel in my hand the balance
was really nice
see all that space around your tang with
that room for that blade to move inside
the guard it could just create so much
stress that it cut loose right there at
the corner if it were all tight there
would be any stress there's no
discoloration here so it's not that
there were it was a crack here before
your grain structure looks fine it was a
well-designed piece but obvious law
Dan unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test which means that we
can no longer test it
I'd like to invite you to shake our
hands shake your competitor's hand and
then please leave the forge
it hurts but my sword breaking it's
going to be a reminder that I have to
push harder and be better Randy the
strength and efficiency of your weapon
in the kill test have earned you the
title of force and fire champion and a
check for how much oh no that's right
ten thousand dollars good job brother I
won forward and far it's reality how do
you feel good to be a champion and be
recognized as a good blade Smith is a
pretty good this is my happy and
exciting place I think if you didn't
recognize it
thank you
[Music]
the soda gourami holy geez
oh my God one of the most intimidating
and versatile Japanese pole weapons the
Soto gourami was part of the key Arsenal
for Samurai police during the 17th
century featuring lethal spikes and
hooks police were able to capture
violent offenders from The Distance by
using the weapon to latch onto the
suspects stopping them in their tracks
although primarily used in defense the
sharp spikes along with the spike butt
cap made it a menacing and brutal weapon
when in combat today the Soto garame's
devastating use can be seen in the HBO
television series Westworld alright
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your sodigarami will do I will take your
weapons and stab and try to snag this
ballistics dummy Rita you're up first
you ready for this hi all right let's do
this
all right
we let's talk about your satigarami the
times you have here penetrates the hook
you have here will rip this person apart
and more importantly your weapon
appeal
all right Justin your attorney you ready
to have fun yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
all right Justin the times you have here
it's more of a stabbing time rather than
a grabbing this is a grabbing weapon but
that hook does grab on to that overall
sir your weapon
killed
all right bladesmiths it's time for the
strength test the dreaded ice block chop
remember this is not about what these
weapons do to the ice blocks but with
those ice blocks due to your weapons and
Rita you're up first you get points for
theme I mean
laughs
you ready it doesn't matter right no it
doesn't matter
foreign
[Music]
got a little bit more of a bend in this
one tine here
but everything else is pretty much the
way it was going in definitely held up
did his job good job thank you
all right Justin your turn you ready yes
I am
foreign
so you survived the strength test this
is a very strong uh well-built head for
this but it's built more like a spear
than it is for catching I mean I'm not
sure how effective it would be at
snagging the opponent but uh it's a
Devastator it certainly did the job good
job
foreign
bladesmiths welcome to the sharpness
test the Sandman Pierce and capture
to test the sharpness I will take your
weapon Pierce and try to control this
Sandman relay up first you ready for
this
[Music]
foreign
the points you have on your times here
definitely penetrate when you thrust
into that but it doesn't Slice on the
way out or capture as well as it should
your hook over here did its job overall
it will cut and control
all right Justin your turn so you ready
yes I am
oh
that's not good
well Justin we have a problem yes sir
this wasn't pinned was it no the impact
from all these tests loosened it up and
of course it came off
[Music]
Justin you brought in a beautifully
crafted weapon however you've suffered a
catastrophic failure in our final test
and unfortunately you cannot be our
Fortune fire Champion congratulations
coming on Forest and fire I'll put my
all into it and I feel like I made a
good weapon but uh just came up short on
a little bit of the fit and finish and
other than that I'm happy with it
[Music]
Rita congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations how do you feel
right now
come on forward and Shake our hands
good job
it's been a very positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do something
amazing like this
I hope this will help me become an
inspiration to kids because I can say
look if you see something and you want
to try it give it a try
hey Webelos your scout leader is the new
Fortune fire Champion I'm bringing it
home should I have a group hug please
thank you you guys oh my God
thank you
the jien
the Gian sword first appeared in China
all the way back in the 7th Century BC
wisely designed the sharp lethal tip was
ideal for Rapid cuts and stabs while the
wide body aided in deflecting attacks
considered an elite weapon due to the
amount of training needed to master the
sword the straight double-edged blade
was built for subtle instant strikes
requiring a level of precision in
finesse that only comes from a true
swordsman because it was so difficult to
master the Xian was removed in Mass from
the battlefield however many are still
involved in ceremonies and featured in
films including Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon
all right blade space welcome to kill
test
now your Gian swords look beautiful but
are they deadly well to find that out I
will take your weapon and do some
slashes and thrust on this ballistic
dummy
Ben's here first you ready Gabriel
okay
all right Vince let's talk about your
Gian sword up here overall
I like the Aesthetics of this sword now
your handle construction is within scale
of this blade it's comfortable when I
wrap around it
now your Edge
is razor sharp in thrusting it cuts out
and when you swing you can feel the
impact of this sword overall sir
it'll kill wanted to hear that good job
hey Casey you got the stomach for this
you're next I'm ready
[Music]
all right Casey let's talk about your
Gian sword here first up I like the
lines that you have with your sword here
and the Damascus pattern I can
appreciate that
and now in cutting it was so much fun
just to be able to slice over and over
and over
with ease with a blade that moves
this sir
will kill thank you
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
now to test the edge holding ability of
your blades and the overall strength and
construction I'm going to take each of
your swords and smash them repeatedly
into these heavy pots now I'm not really
concerned what your blades do to the
pots even though it's going to look
really cool and be a lot of fun I want
to see what the pots are going to your
blades and edges
Vince you're up first you ready to go
yes sir
foreign
still straight and true
but the problem is
doing your pommel
your threads here didn't go very far
through so Pummel broke loose
bit of a problem
Vince your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure after three shots
on the pots a Pummel is critical to a
one-handed weapon's retention but that
doesn't mean that this competition is
over Casey
these are some pretty strong terracotta
pots and you'll have to survive Three
Pot shots to make it out of here I feel
ready all right Jay you ready
if the pots can knock off a pommel they
could do anything it all comes down to
this got a little bit of knots in my
stomach let's see what happens
foreign
Casey congratulations your blade
survived Vince unfortunately you cannot
continue testing please exit the forge
I'm disappointed I think I made a hell
of a blade it was still sharp after the
three terracottas
but the blade needs to be a hundred
percent
mine was 98 percent
and he failed Casey congratulations you
are the force and fire champion and
that's the title that comes with a check
for 10 000 big ones buddy
congratulations
great steel and a great job on the
handle too
proven to myself that I can make a damn
good blade for me that's nothing better
the sword of gujien
the sword of gujian is an exquisitely
crafted Gian sword wielded by King
guccian ruler of China's Kingdom of you
after brutal battles between the you and
the Wu King guccian was forced into
slavery in exchange for sparing his
people after three years of servitude
King guccian rebuilt his Empire
conquered the dwindling Kingdom of Wu
and was bestowed this sword featuring a
sharp lethal tip intricate blue crystal
and turquoise guard the sword was just
as ornate as it was deadly more than
2500 years later the sword was
discovered by archaeologists in a
remarkable condition still with a razor
sharp edge it has been called one of the
most intact artifacts ever found
blade Smiths welcome to the kill test
[Music]
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do according to his
historic design I will take your weapon
deliver some killing thrust and blows on
this ballistics dummy for us are you up
for this yes sir let's do this
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
about your weapon here and it's very
forward heavy what makes it hard to
handle is the fact that you have a very
skinny handle right here a lot of these
movements your blade went up on contact
was spinning in my hand
I had to adjust several times to make
sure that I stay on the edge over here
now the edge is sharp once it makes
contact you slash it digs Deep Over
ulcer it will kill
all right Caleb you're up you ready
let's see it
[Applause]
all right Caleb first up the blade in
itself balance wise
I think you nailed it now your handle
construction it's avoid it's actually
comfortable because of the balance and a
very sharp edge all the cuts are very
very deep overall sir
it'll heal
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
the gong chop
tends to strength and durability of your
edges as well as the overall
construction of your storage of gujian
I'm going to be chopping them into these
gongs of course you're up first you
ready yes sir
[Applause]
[Music]
well Forest your sword did take some
damage on the edge there's some rolls
sort of crushed in right here your
handle is really small a bigger handle
would help me control this really well
but all that being said that much damage
and a big strength test like this
well done
thank you
all right Caleb you're up you ready heck
yeah man
well Caleb he did a great job with the
Damascus I love to see this kind of
stuff it's beautiful your blade is still
straight true
and the weight on this is phenomenal
there is one big issue though
your handle
it's loose now
your handle is coming apart I can move
it and their pommel is also loose if
these were right and tight and held in
place then it tends to help everything
else stay where it is but just a little
bit of play in this guard can send
shockwaves right down the handle but uh
gotta say that's one heck of a blade
thanks Justin thank you you know this
handle that's really causing the issue
now yes sir
so we've got a pretty mobile opening
that has a corresponding split on the
back side of the handle not only is it
loose but the material that's loose has
sharp edges okay yeah I mean this would
require either Taping that up or wearing
a glove and now we're not testing the
same as the other one okay then that's a
gorgeous sword
the handle's gone the tape kills me uh
yeah okay
okay
now we've continued with blades that had
loose Parts before
we've continued with blaze that had
split handles before your
handle has cracked
however the combination of the two
things has made our blade unsafe to
continue with any testing and therefore
you cannot be our forged and fire
Champion I'd like to invite you to shake
our hands shake your competitor's hand
and then I have to ask you to please
leave the forge
I may not be the fortune fire Champion
but a man I'm walking out of here with
my head held high and I'm proud
[Music]
forced congratulations you are the forge
and fire champion and that is a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars my friend good job a month
forward I'm thrilled that I'm the
Champion hasn't even soaked in yet and
next day or two I'll really realize
what's happened being a forge and fire
Champion means I succeeded in the goal
that I wanted to reach
this is for everyone at home and I'm
coming home with forged and fire
Champion yeehaw
foreign
originating in the 1500s the Jumanji
Yari was carried by Japanese soldiers
known as the ashigaru these peasant foot
soldiers relied on the long-shafted
spear for its reach and versatility in
combat using the weapon's double-edged
crossbars to disarm and pull mounted
samurai from their horses ashigaru could
then employ the razor-sharp central
blade to fatally skewer the Fallen enemy
and all from a comfortable distance
today video game enthusiasts can unleash
the Jumanji yari's devastating
capabilities in the game shadow fight 2.
the Yari with its long handle and
multi-pronged spear makes it a trifecta
of points and edges in a deadly weapon
to see what kind of lethal damage your
weapon will do I will take your Yari and
deliver multiple slashes thrust on his
picarcus but you're up first you ready
oh I'm ready
foreign
let's talk about your yachty here we
felt that it had very good balance to it
that on the initial slash right here it
dug in into flesh then it hit the spine
the transference of energy hit a weak
spot into your handle over here but it
still had a secondary cut all the way
through I would consider your blade a
Kill
thank you it was mine mine was
beautiful well-made
and some wood grain just you know
who I your weapons suffered a
catastrophic failure now that's bad
however you're not out of this
competition yet Jacob your Yari still
must perform in this kill test let's see
what happens right now I'm feeling
nauseous
Hearts behind my chest my hands are
sweaty and um
just can't wait to see how it actually
goes down
all right Jacob let's talk about your
yachty in the initial swing instead of
being able to cut cleanly with this part
to cut through this got in the way with
the angle that it had but let's talk
about these particular blades they are
sharp enough to penetrate into the pig
carcass the thrust is really devastating
and very deep into that your handle
Construction
it stayed true no issues at all overall
your weapon will kill thank you sir
my Yari held up and I'm just
you get hard well Foo had the blades of
your Yari were beautifully constructed
the overall weapon was very elegant
however your shaft broke in our first
test and we cannot move forward in this
competition because that is a
catastrophic weapon failure
and I have to ask you to please leave
the forge I was really confident going
into the competition and I felt like my
Yari was going to really perform a lot
better than Jacobs and it's just pure
irony all the way down
Jacob you are the forced and fire
champion and will be receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars good job
you feel right now
amazing
prove that I can actually come out here
at 19 and compete with serious knife
makers thank you sir really I would have
liked to beat fuad in a different way
but I'm a fortune fire Champion ten
thousand dollars
it's awesome
Spanish navaja
rising to popularity in the 1600s the
Spanish navaja was a deadly folding
weapon common in duels and street brawls
this blade could be folded into the
handle and locked in place making it
easy to conceal it featured a locking
ratchet mechanism which kept the blade
in place
the ratchet sound of a navaja opening
was also used to intimidate foes wielded
with the blade up a strike from the
nabaja was difficult to Parry and wounds
were often fatal the bajas were often
inscribed with pithy phrases in Spanish
boasting about the deadliness of the
blade the Spanish navaja an iconic
folding weapon from history it's even
said to influence the American buoy
knife to see what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do wall ticker Spanish
then deliver killing blows on this deer
carcass
Matthew you're up first you ready oh
yeah
okay Matthew nice and solid work right
here but I'm still recovering from an
injury so please welcome Anthony Palmer
Anthony is one of the chief instructors
of merkaida Kali today he will have the
pleasure of wielding your Spanish
my biggest concern going into testing is
the sharpness of my blade
your blade is beautiful and it's also
solid in its feel it lacerates easily
you can see it shop right through the
spine now one of the pieces here came
flying out during the test
but in terms of the sharpness and the
wieldability of your blade it will kill
oh yeah okay wait it's your turn you
ready you bet
this way I can hear the mechanism
working in there
foreign
the third of that deer carcass hitting
the floor is absolutely the sound of ten
thousand dollars I feel like I'm ahead
that's where I want to be I want to win
it
all right Wade your blade is sharp thank
you the one issue is it's kind of
rickety here even while it was being
wielded but despite being riggity it's
deadly and it will kill thank you next
up is a strength test okay
to test the strength and durability of
your Edge as well as the overall
construction I'm going to smash into
this bamboo with your Spanish navajas
Matthew you're up first are you ready oh
yeah
[Music]
well Matthew this thing's worn a hell of
a chopper held together beautifully
there was slight glimping that happened
up here near the tip but it's pretty
darn Sharp
very well done thank you
Wade you're up next you ready
yeah I'm ahead he's ahead I'm ahead he's
ahead we've been this way the whole time
it's a battle I want to win it
foreign
we have a problem
on about the third strike things started
to get kind of loose and that torquing
and the stress made your scales pop off
the only thing holding the cutting end
to the handle end are these thin brass
sheets and I don't have confidence in
their strength this blade has lost its
structural Integrity it's no longer safe
to test
weighed due to the catastrophic failure
of the structural Integrity of your
weapon we cannot continue testing that
blade so I have to ask you to please
leave the forge
I thought I could beat down a door with
that thing but you know apparently you
can
Matthew congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion and that's a title
that comes with a check for 10 grand
good job
I just spawned forest and fire and I am
so excited being here as a winner means
a lot to me I've had so much support
throughout my life to do what I am
passionate about and my passion has
proven to be what I should be doing I'm
supposed to be a metal worker stay with
it don't stop keep going
foreign
spirit
the Messiah lion spear gets its name
from an East African tribe A fearsome
Warrior Nomads that date their Origins
back to the 15th century traditionally
used to hunt lions the weapon features a
double-edged blade at one end and a
fearsome Spike at the other this allows
a messiah Warrior to engage his opponent
in close quarters or at a distance
while today lion hunts have been
replaced the deadly spear lives on in
popular culture and can even be spotted
in the film Laura Croft Tomb Raider the
Cradle of life to see how lethal your
weapon is I will take your Spear and
deliver lethal blows on this big carcass
Matt you're up first are you ready as
I'll ever be let's do this
what I'm most worried about is lateral
force on this spear because it's a very
thin Sleek spear
[Music]
much
well that sucks
Matt I'm not gonna sugarcoat it this is
bad your weapon has suffered a
catastrophic failure and cannot continue
with testing however John we can't just
declare you the forged and fire Champion
your blade has to hold up for at least a
stab and a slash on this carcass Doug
[Music]
I don't know what to say I don't know
what to think I've never been more you
know nervous in my life
I'm hoping and praying that it doesn't
break in the same spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blade Smith Sasser designed these tests
push your weapons to the Limit John your
blade survived the two cuts on our
carcass
Matt that means unfortunately your blade
did not make the cut and I have to ask
you to please leave the forge
Kevin what I know now I would have gone
back and really tried chopping some
things very hard with the spirit
hopefully broken the handle myself I'm
really happy for John maybe I'm not
happy to lose to John but I'm glad John
Won
John congratulations you built a weapon
to held up in our test that makes you
our new forged and fire champion who
also receives a check for 10 grand
how do you feel right now I feel like a
million bucks but I guess 10 grand will
do all right well come on over here and
Shake our hands good job thank you very
good I'm gonna have to uh talk to my
wife about what I'm allowed to to do
with this prize money I know one thing
my baby girl's gonna get in a little new
wardrobe
the Scottish Claymore
the Claymore was used by Scottish
mercenaries in battle from the 15th to
17th century
the weapon usually 55 inches in length
would have to be held with both hands
and Swordsmen were unable to carry a
shield
symbolizing fearlessness on the
battlefield a klansmen would swing The
Sword in figure eight movements
decapitating and dismembering
adversaries Legend has it that Scottish
Knight William Wallace used a claymore
in the war for Scottish independence
this epic weapon has been immortalized
in the classic movie Braveheart
thanks miss this is the kill test the
term Claymore in Gaelic means great
sword to see how lethal your weapon is
and to test its functionality according
to its historic design I will deliver
two killing blows on this animal carcass
Scott you're up you ready I'm ready
let's do it
I see the pigs and I'm thinking oh crap
I've cut test against pigs and they
don't cut very easily at all
okay the moment Doug hits the pig and I
hear that thud
I'm like crap uh Scott we have a little
problem here the hardness of your blade
is a little bit on the uh flexible side
it did not even cut the carcass so that
brings into question also the sharpness
of your Edge
I think and we're pretty much done
it will not kill
ah
this is a failure
Jonathan you're up are you ready
absolutely I'm confident that I made a
good blade
the blade is hard and it's ready to cut
this is going to be spectacular
oh boy
[Music]
Jonathan we have a major blade
malfunction it did initially cut through
but then it probably hit the spine it
just exploded
I'm not completely confident that I'm
going to come out with the win here but
my blade cuts and that's more than Scots
Jonathan your blade suffered
catastrophic failure for safety reasons
we can no longer continue testing on
your blade since both weapons have
suffered malfunctions Dave will now
decide on the best course of action to
move forward with the competition
Dave
in the Viking sagas swords broke in the
song of Roland swords broke but bent
swords can be straightened
so we'd like to give you an opportunity
Scott to straighten that weapon so we
can take it Forward into a sharpness
test to help us determine our winner
so Scott why don't you take a moment and
straighten your weapon okay
foreign
Not only was the Claymore a battlefield
Intimidator but it was also a Scottish
symbol for physical prowess and strength
so what I'm going to do to test the edge
of your blade is I am going to cut into
this piece of sheet steel so Scott are
you ready let's do it
[Music]
I've got a 50 50 shot that it's going to
do well you know I just want to see what
happens
I am desperate to win this ten thousand
dollars on the line here
I don't want to watch
well Scott
there's actually still an edge here
we can see what it did to the steel
should have had the pig made out of
steel it probably would have got better
all in all well done thank you overall
I'm
this was the first time I've ever made a
blade of this size of this complexity
gentlemen this by far was our most
difficult challenge to date
congratulations you both delivered
your Scottish Claymores but there can
only be one champion
congratulations you are the forged and
fire Champion but
right now
Jonathan unfortunately your blade did
not make the cut Jonathan the design of
your blade was really going in the right
direction basically once that blade
snapped it just wasn't anything else we
could do to test that blade so that's
why we're letting you go Jonathan please
surrender your way
it's a great pleasure man thank you sir
I'll be back
absolutely proud of myself with every
failure there's a great lesson learned
and I think I'm moving forward from here
Scott congratulations you were the
forced to fire champion and you'll be
receiving a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
I'd never won anything in my life that's
like this try your best and you learn
from it and then you do it again until
you perfect it I mean even though the
sword didn't do what I wanted it's still
okay I won
I'm certainly going to be buying drinks
tonight
[Music]
blade Smiths you're probably wondering
why there's five of you and only four
anvils that's because one of you will be
eliminated before we even fire up the
first Forge
up first is our qualifying test Ben
bladesmiths in this sudden elimination
round I will be smashing your knives
into these blocks of ice 10 times
Steve you're up first are you ready
let's do it
it's W-2 that had to be a chopper so I
tried to design for that got some weight
up front that'll hopefully carry it
through here I think my blade will
destroy that ice
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
on the 10th strike the knife broke
that's because if you look closely at
this blade you'll see that there's a
brown section of the crack the brown
section was an old crack that happened
probably in the quench it's been there a
while it's actually rusted the rest of
the edge is still pretty sharp but at
the end of the day
it did bring
Steve that's what we call a catastrophic
blade failure and you all know what that
means but it's not over yet each of your
blades must survive all 10 ice block
chops in order to move forward
you guys will be counting to 10 like you
never have before in your life
well Brian you're up next are you ready
let's do it
this is the longest blade I've ever made
I put a maple handle on it I don't think
I'm nervous at all I know that Steve's
blade just broke but I know my Blade's
solid
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well Brian your Edge held up perfectly
it's like it never even saw the ice it's
still like the minute you brought it in
got a nice finish to it it's got a great
shape very well done thank you Matt
you're up you ready I'm ready
they used a piece of W2 I made it short
robust strong I think it feels good in
the hands so I think it's going to do
well I hope
[Music]
[Music]
nice
well Matt
your knife held up very well it's got a
very thick Edge
still Sharp
still in one piece
well done thank you Tyler you're up you
ready swing it like you mean it
I made it out of W-2 it may be the best
blade that I've ever made but I just
hope mine holds up and I make it to 10.
[Music]
well Tyler this extreme curve that you
have here made it so that as I was
chopping the ice I ended up hitting my
knuckle on the ice instead of the blade
but uh it held up the edge is still
Sharp well done thanks Joey you're up
you ready let's get her done brother
I've never made a competition Chopper
before so I've seen what one looked like
and went out and did my best to recreate
it I'm really very nervous I'm hoping
this it's going to do the job and
survive through that chop
foreign
[Music]
perfectly I like the shape of it the
weight of it it's a great Chopper did
some damage on the ice
well done thank you sir
well gentlemen I don't think that any
blade Smith is really prepared for the
ice block chop and how devastating it
can be that being said Steve because
your blade suffered a catastrophic
weapons failure I have to ask you to
please leave the forge
to get eliminated before getting to work
in the Forge is really really
disappointing but hopefully this is just
going to take me to the next level of
being a better Smith
the arming sword
[Music]
the arming sword was the sort of choice
for medieval European Knights during an
era of advanced armor when swords needed
to penetrate both armor and flesh the
Blade's Point has a distinctive taper
allowing pinpoint thrusts into
vulnerable areas on an enemy a central
Fuller in the blade reduced its weight
making it a well-balanced and effective
one-handed weapon wielded with a shield
in the opposite hand Knights were
protected as they delivered deadly blows
powerful enough to cleave a skull into
in 1429 French troops made a heroic
counter-attack at the siege of orleon
led by Joan of Arc wielding the arming
sword
That's The lethality of your arming
sword I will deliver slashes and thrust
on these poor carcasses John you're up
first you ready for this yes sir let's
do this
that hide is super thick to get through
that you really need a very fine Edge
and not a lot of weight behind it and I
didn't build that
all right John let's talk about your
arming sword here it's heavy
it did cut on some parts of the carcass
other parts it just bounced off frosting
wise though it did what it was designed
for
this will kill thank you sir all right
Drew you're up you ready yes sir let's
do this when I saw John's blade hit the
carcass first few times it didn't really
cut so great so I'm worried about my
sharpness on my blade
oh nice
foreign
[Music]
this is a very sharp blade a great
frosting blade and I like how you put a
counter bounce right here because all
the weight is nicely distributed so I
can thrust and Slash
your blade sir will kill
thank you good job thank you
foreign
test one of my favorites the ice block
chop
and we supersized it what I'm going to
do is take each of your swords I'm gonna
beat them repeatedly and viciously into
this big chunk of ice it's going to test
the overall construction of your sword
as well as its Edge holding ability now
what your swords do to the ice is
secondary compared to what the ice does
to your swords
and John you're up first how you feeling
buddy nervous well we're gonna do it
anyway so yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
well this is very heavy very hard to
control
also aside from having gaps in your
shoulders here you've got a pretty good
bend in the blade and that was there
before I started
not a lot of edge left but you survived
Drew how you feeling I'm ready good so
am I
Jay's tough on blades ice it's tough on
blades it doesn't matter who's swinging
on it and I'm just praying at this point
that nothing fails
foreign
[Music]
blade is still razor sharp which is very
impressive with a nice block chop
that being said the ice block chop is
meant to be brutal it's meant to test
the overall structure Integrity of your
sword from tip to pummel
problem is I'm holding your Pummel in
his hand instead of this hand so that's
an issue yeah
Drew
your blade has suffered a catastrophic
failure
I have to ask you to please leave the
forge
[Music]
I'm sad that my blade failed but I feel
really good about the fact that I was
able to make something completely
outside of my wheelhouse but none of
that matters if the bomber comes flying
off if the functionality is in there the
Aesthetics really do not matter I had a
ton of fun I would do it again in a
second I'm super excited to get back to
the West Coast and just get back to work
chipping away at my custom orders
John congratulations you're the next
forage fire Champion good job
you'll be receiving a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel I
didn't want to win like that but I feel
pretty good
I made butter knives in the first round
I come back with a beast of an arm and
sword and now unfortunate fire Champion
good job brother I get home the first
thing I'm doing is buying a press and
get right back out to the shop and
forward some more is only driving me to
do it more
your final challenge is to forge a
Marine Corps officer's sword also known
as a mammal Loop
since 1825 the mammaloo sword has been
awarded to U.S Marines to recognize
extraordinary service
this tradition began when the rulers of
Tripoli bestowed this weapon upon Marine
lieutenant Presley o'banon for his
bravery during the battle of derna the
weapon itself originates from the
Ottoman Empire in Persia with many
similarities to the Persian shamshir
featuring a thin blade shallow curve and
its signature inward curved pommel this
deadly sword was ideal for Cavalry and
foot soldiers to deliver lethal slashes
and thrusts on their enemy
this blade was so dangerous Legend had
it that it was nearly unbreakable and
could cut a person in two
all right Marines welcome to the Keel
test
to find out what lethal damage your
weapon will do I'll take care of your
weapon and there were killing blows of
this ballistics dummy trip you up first
you ready for this get it killer hoorah
going into this cute test man I just
hope that it performs better than the
k-bar that I made
foreign
yikes
[Music]
holy moly
all right Tripp first up the handle
construction it is comfortable
your edge here is sharp even cutting
through the skull no issues at all no
chipping no glinting and when you thrust
with this it penetrates and cuts all the
way out overall sir your weapon
will kill all right we Raw all right
Gene you're next you ready let's do this
let's do this
I'm pretty darn nervous I know my blade
is sharp but I don't know if it's strong
enough to get through these tests I'm
really worried that at the end of this
test my sword is going to look like a
pretzel
foreign
[Music]
all right Gene your weapon picked up a
warp right here okay your handle coupled
with blood all over it made it very
slippery and hard to hold on to because
it's blocky and smooth and I lost my
grip on it that's a very dangerous thing
to happen when you're trying to wield
the weapon but your Edge is still sharp
your tip is still thrustable and more
importantly it will kill
that'll work
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test so to test the overall
construction of your blade and see if
they're going to hold an edge I'll be
smashing into these pots
now remember this test is not about what
your swords do to those pots but those
pots do your swords trip you up you
ready ready okay
these clay pots are thick they're brutal
I mean they'll send a shock wave down
this blade there's no telling what's
going to happen
yep holy moly
ah no
we'll trip a few things before we get to
the obvious your handle construction
very comfortable felt really good in my
hand felt like I could do a lot with it
but
right there at the edge there's that
little brown spot
he had a micro crack on that edge yeah
so as soon as I hit that potty Cutlass I
love to feel its shape and its look but
obvious problem
all right trip while I know any Marine
could take that blade and still continue
to fight in this competition your blade
suffered a catastrophic failure after
one strike on that vase Gene your blade
only has to survive one strike on these
pots
foreign
championship for forged and fire flies
on one swing and I've got a big old warp
in my blade so it's not over yet
nice job
Gene first off you're in one piece you
picked up that bend earlier on but you
didn't pick up any more in this test
strong blade held up good job thank you
all right trip looks like Gene's blade
held up that means that you cannot move
forward to represent the Marine Corps in
our next challenge please leave the
forge super disappointed there's really
no way to tell that you have like any
minor cracks or anything like that so
you just hey you find out when you test
them that's how we found out today yeah
brother Jane's gonna freaking bring home
that battle of the branches Marine Corps
anfield he's winning it for the Marine
Corps
Gene congratulations you've won this
competition and that means that you're
going to be moving forward into our
Battle of the branches final competition
to represent the Marine Corps at the
Marine Corps Anvil and that's going to
give you an opportunity to win a check
for fifty thousand dollars good job
brother
holy cow I did not see this coming it's
been a fun ride up until now but now I
got to represent the Marines so now it's
it's game on and it's about to get real
those other Branch service members
better look out
the Chinese war sword oh
the Chinese war sword was a traditional
weapon of China's peasant armies
beginning with the Qing Dynasty and
continuing through the 20th century
similar to the Falcon the war sword is a
massive two-handed cleaving sword that
generates a tremendous amount of
swinging power while slashing and
chopping through opponents with a
frightening reputation as an instrument
of decapitation this blade vanquished
enemies during the Boxer Rebellion and
later during clashes with Japanese
forces in the second sino-japanese war
all right blade Smiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do I will take your
Chinese war sword and deliver one strike
on this Ram carcass let's see how deadly
they are
Bobby up first you ready for this yes
sir let's do this
my heart's just bouncing out of my chest
you've got the skin you've got the bones
you've got to hide I only get one shot
at this Ram carcass
trick
[Music]
all right Bobby
one and done
as much as this is very intimidating in
its look it is crafted nicely it's got a
beautiful look to its finish the balance
is just right for a two-handed sword a
little forward heavy but it tells you
that's where the power is your Edge is
sharp even cutting through the spine and
Bones no issues no glinting no rolls
overall sir your Chinese war sword
little Keel thank you sir
all right well your turn ready yes sir
I'm ready let's do this
Doug picks up my weapon and at this
point all the nerves are out the window
I'm just excited he's walking towards
this Rams carcass and I'm ready to see
it fly right through
good job buddy
right well let's talk about your Chinese
war sword here first up it's a very
bulky handle it's rounded so as you get
a good grip on it you can feel it start
to spread my hands around but the
wrapping that you put around it does
allow me to get a good grip on it so
good on that and one shot one kill
overall sir your weapon it will kill
thank you sir
oh I just felt a frightening chill must
be the strength test Jay
you boys remember me yes sir yes sir
welcome to the ice block chop
this is going to test not only your Edge
and your heat treat but the overall
construction of your swords now what
your blades do to the ice I'm not too
concerned about I want to see what the
ice is going to do to your blades Bobby
up first how you feeling
ready to go me too let's do it
this is not just a nice block this
thing's a glacier
foreign
Bobby
still razor sharp no rolls no glints
nothing
everything's still tight
I mean one of the swings I was able to
split that block
so it's got good feel just nice job
overall thank you
okay well how you feeling I'm nervous
but I'm excited okay I'm just excited so
this is gonna be brutal I'm really
worried about the crack in my Tang right
now chopping through a block that big is
so tough if there are any compromises in
my blade this is where they're going to
show their head
foreign
[Music]
well big problem sir right where you did
your very rough Hollow Grind it's a
couple dark spots right in here
and with that thin spot right there it
was enough to allow that blade to just
snap right in half on the first swing
so did not survive but
good effort thank you sir
well well sometimes this competition is
full of tough breaks and you've had one
on the first strike against this ice
block in our strength test unfortunately
we cannot continue testing your blade
against your opponents and for that
reason I'd like to invite you to shake
our hands shake your opponent's hand and
then please leave the force to your
right come on my friend yes sir
excellent work dude thank you brother
it's tough having a blade break is
obviously you know it's a tremendous
failure but at the end of the day I did
the best I could with the tools I had
and I'm still proud of the piece that I
put forward
this competition has given me the
inspiration to move forward and
challenge myself in new ways
Bobby you are the forge and fire
champion and that's the title that comes
with a check for ten thousand dollars
good job brother
come on forward my friend
great job great work I feel on top of
the world right now that's a great base
man that was promising this is not just
a win for me this is a win for my family
my friends the other Smiths that I teach
in the Forge this goes a long ways for
our whole community
the Zulu War ax
the Zulu War ax is a deadly and elegant
weapon now used primarily for ceremonial
purposes by the Zulu tribe in South
Africa passed down from generation to
generation this weapon was effective
against enemies as well as serving as a
symbol of political power and resistance
to Colonial Rule featuring an elongated
Arrowhead shape that swelled in the
center this razor-sharp blade provided a
way for officers to reach over their own
formations to tear down and Destroy
enemy Shields the current King of the
Zulu Nation Goodwill sway latini Wheels
this weapon in marches to this day
your Zulu War ax look quite scary but
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage they can do to find that
out I will take your weapon delivers
some chops and slashes on this more
carcass
that's in your purse you ready for this
let's do it let's do it
I'm feeling nervous anxious this is not
going to be an easy test I mean this
bore it's got tough skin bones but I
want to see this Blade Chop this board
in half
all right
foreign
[Music]
War ax
it's quite surprising that something
this light with not a lot of metal can
cut deep into this boar carcass
your blade stayed true the handle
construction is all void enough to wear
even though it tapers I have a very good
feel for it overall sir
it will kill
thank you all right Western your returns
are you ready yes sir let's do this
my first concern is a handle braking uh
after that it's that Junction between
the blade and the tank I mean it's a
weak spot anything can happen there
thank you
foreign
[Music]
warax here what I find interesting here
is that the design of this blade there's
a sweet spot in here with a little bit
of weight so that first swing alone cut
in very deep there are no glints or
rolls on it the handle construction is
avoid enough to where I get a good grip
and I can get a good feel on it and more
importantly sir it will kill thank you
blade Smiths welcome to the strength
test the ammo box chop I'm going to test
the strength and durability of your axes
by Smashing them into these ammo boxes
remember this test is all about what
those boxes do to your axes and not the
other way around Dustin you're up first
you ready let's do it all right
I know I nailed my heat treat but this
test is brutal and I just keep thinking
please survive please survive
foreign
[Music]
got an obvious issue here I'm looking at
your grain in here it's beautiful it's
nice and velvety tight but right here
there's a little dark spot which was a
crack it happened right where the join
of your tang and your blade is and that
little crack is a stress Riser and it
leads to Big failure true
all right Dustin your blade has broke on
the third strike against these ammo
boxes in our strength test now that
doesn't mean that you're out of this
competition your competitor still has to
endure the same rigors Weston that means
that your blade must survive three
strikes against these ammo boxes and if
it does you'll be the new force and fire
Champion taking home that check for 10
grand you guys ready for this let's do
it let's do it all right Ben
all right Weston how you feeling nervous
I would be too clearly this is not an
easy test and if Dustin's blade broke
there's a good chance mine will as well
I'm just hoping it can take three
strikes
[Music]
[Music]
good job thanks
[Music]
well Weston it held up nice job this is
a nice light ax a lot of fun to swing
with every swing I could feel the
reverberation just it kind of jiggling
in my hands it was singing really well
done thank you thank you
Weston congratulations your blade held
up Dustin that means that your blade
doesn't make the cut I'd like to invite
you to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then exit the
forge
great job man thank you sir
I'm pretty bummed out I really wanted to
win this whole thing Weston
congratulations Bud thank you good job
but this has been one of the greatest
experiences of my life this is not the
result I wanted but at the end of the
day I'm here I'm alive I'm healthy so
I'm happy
and congratulations you made a beautiful
Zulu War ax and that makes you the
forest and fire Champion that's a title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars come forward Shake our hands my
friend I have the 4 scores and fire
champion and I feel elated I came here
to prove that I could compete with some
incredibly talented Smiths and I came
out on top it's been a blast
the nimcha
the ninja is a single-handed scimitar
widely used throughout North Africa
this unique weapon featured a hooked
handle knuckle guard and forward
pointing quillians that were designed as
a defensive tool to catch an opponent's
blade featuring a deep Fuller on both
sides the sword was light quick and
deadly on the battlefield largely made
of recycled blades the ninja could be
forged quickly and in large quantities
and was a crucial weapon used by the
ottoman soldiers during the Great Siege
of malt in 1565.
placements welcome to the kill test
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage your nymshas will do I
will take your weapon delivers some
lethal blows on this war carcass right
in Europe first you ready for this make
some barbecue cat no right let's try
seeing the boar carcass I'm smiling from
ear to ear I wanted to see him cut up
four carcass in half with it but I know
it's razor sharp
[Music]
all right Ryan I don't know what's a
bigger Beast the poor carcass or your
nymsha right here this is a heavy sword
everything about the weight that you
have on this allows for a very very deep
cut but it's a lot of work because of
the weight it's very forward heavy but
overall
it will kill thank you all right Steve
your attorney so you ready yes sir let's
do this
I'm excited Ryan's blade kelt well so I
know I've got some competition here mine
better perform
okay
all right Steve let's talk about your
namecha right here
first up the handle construction it's
smooth it's not blocky so I like that
you have it oh void over there and it
marries in
before I start the testing your blade
had a little bit kick off to the side
but after the test it stayed the same
your edge with a thinner profile like
that cuts deep also it is a much lighter
sword than your competitors I can
control with every slash overall sir
your blade feels good
you will Keel thank you sir
bladesmiths welcome to the strength test
Hiller and pop chop to test the strength
and durability of your Edge as well as
the overall construction of your [ __ ]
I'll be chopping into these pots and
pillars remember this test is all about
with the Target Studio blades and not
what your blades do to the Target
Brian you're up first you ready for this
tear it up all right man
I know I'm behind the eight ball right
now
I need to perform really well in the
strengthness test
hopefully I'll pull back up into line
with him and be evened up
well Ryan in the strength test the edge
that you have on here took a slight roll
like I I can't see it so much as I can
feel it
the rest of it is is really wicked sharp
it's still all in one piece nice job
thank you
Steve you're up next you ready for this
yes sir all right cool
feel pretty good I think my blade cut a
little better than Ryan's maybe but he
didn't have that can't and flaw on his
blade so I think I've got a blade
that'll hold up to it
my hands
well Steve I got a problem man
when I picked this sword up I was
excited it's nice light got a good shape
to it but looking at your steel here
is a really big grain in here it really
could have used more thermal cycling I'm
guessing I don't know how you how you
heat treated this but
however you did it ended up brittle
well Steve your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure during our strength
test it can no longer continue with
testing therefore I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then please exit
the forge
congratulations
I'm disappointed my blade broke I didn't
want to go out that way but it is what
it is thank you I just must have got my
heat treat wrong nobody's fault but my
own I didn't win the competition but I
gained so much more than I lost here I'm
on a walk away here with my head held
high and it's going to make me a better
blade Smith for it I've really learned a
lot
Ryan congratulations you are the forge
and fire Champion that is a title that
comes with a check go ahead you can
smile for ten thousand dollars brother
good job
come on
good job right here that's not how I
wanted to win this competition but you
know it is what it is first thing I'm
gonna do is hug and kiss my wife and and
love on the kids and play with them and
get right back in the Forge there's no
sleep for the wicked